bonjour ils vont menacer merci d'être
avec nous ce matin sur rtl france alors
justement avant de parler de la
réouverture des des terrasses 1 quelle
est la situation sanitaire actuellement
en belgique elle est un peu mais là
pensent qu'ils peuvent probablement
expliquer pourquoi on ouvre un peu plus
vite nous avons sur la peine ainsi dans
ces nouveaux cas qui sont au niveau 2 à
peu près 380 par cent mille habitants
deux semaines pour vous rappeler la
france d'à peu près au niveau de 500
actuellement nous avons une diminution
constante de l'occupation délits y
compris des lits de soins intensifs
même si plus de 700 lits de soins
intensifs reste occupé sur les 2000 lits
que le pays possède donc ça c'est une
situation lourde au niveau de l'hôpital
mais qui s'améliore sans cesse depuis
plus de deux semaines actuellement vous
le dites la situation reste lourde est
ce que justement vous pensez que cette
réouverture des terrasses souhaite une
bonne idée ou est ce que c'est c'est le
bon timing
je pense que c'est une mesure au départ
on devrait des terrasses et l'intérieur
est donc conseillé le problème de la
transmission et surtout à l'intérieur
par des micros aérosols l'extérieur en
faut beaucoup plus de possibilités
d'être à l'abri puisque une ventilation
naturelle et dont le fait d'ouvrir
extérieures à notre avis n'est pas réel
problème surtout à les précautions
prises comme on vous l'avait résumé au
début de cette intervention
on l'évoquait tout à l'heure que c'est
une mesure peut-être qui va tenter des
frontaliers notamment
on pense à des français qui pourraient
profiter des terrasses belge dans l'est
dans les semaines à venir est ce que ça
c'est ça peut être un problème alors je
pense que d'autres tous les pays
auraient eu ce genre de problème nous
l'avons vu un moment par rapport à
précédent moment donc je pense que tout
le monde ment d'être d'être
consciencieux d'être d'être prudent
d'une passe précipitée et ce sera aux
gérants de ces terrasses de faire
attention que de manière harmonieuse et
belges des français frontaliers
ils se rencontrent et mike toutes les
précautions nécessaires je pense qu'il
n'y aura pas de réel problème à ce
niveau-là la vaccination aussi
débuté depuis quelques temps maintenant
en belgique où on est on sait à ce sujet
alors pour l'instant les t bonds les
quelque part entre la cinquième et la
septième place au niveau européen ce qui
veut dire que en pratique pratiquement
90 % des plus de 65 ans ont reçu une
dose et un tiers des plus de 18 ans et
la vaccination complète et présente
maintenant j'ai pratiquement un quart
des plus de 65 ans est un grand 10% de
la population de plus de 18 ans elle
avance à pas accéléré puisque on vaccine
à peu près 500 milles à 600 mille
personnes par semaine et au mois de juin
on devrait atteindre à peu près un
million de personnes par semaine
vous le disiez tout à l'heure même si la
situation est légèrement un compliqué en
belgique est ce que justement vous avez
vu une amélioration des chiffres suite
au début de la campagne de vaccination
oui très drastiquement et que plusieurs
pays ont du ca entre des maisons de
repos qui ont été vaccinés en premier
actuellement au pratiquement une
mortalité je dirais presque virtuel liés
aux que vite ils nous prennent plus
aucune place où de rares places au
niveau de l'hospitalisation et les
maisons de repos qui ont été si durement
frappé par tous sont maintenant les
endroits je dirais les + 16 par rapport
aux que vider petit à petit dans
l'inflexion des courbes je pense qu'on
voit vraiment la pac la vaccination oui
quelle est la stratégie justement du
gouvernement belge
quant à quant à la vaccination
aujourd'hui alors qu'on a commencé comme
la veille par les pays par les personnes
depuis 65 ans par tranches de 10 ans
puis des personnes présentant des
comorbidités des facteurs de risque et
on est en plein dans la vaccination des
18 à 65 ans qui ont ces comorbidités et
on devrait d'ici à début juin pouvoir
ouvrir la vaccination à toutes les
personnes qui ont moins de 65 ans ou
même meuble oui moins 65 ans et qui
n'ont pas de comorbidité pour obtenir
normalement à peu près 80 % de gens
ayant reçu de premières doses quelque
part au courant du mois de juillet
merci beaucoup
ils vendent notre scène d'avoir été avec
nous ce matin sur arte france rappelle
et que vous êtes infectiologues au chu
saint-pierre et porte-parole
interfédérale de la lutte contre le coc
vite 19 merci beaucoup